I think he he does face a pretty you
might say bleak
a horizon with with you know issues to
do with the Union uh I mean that's got
to be number one I mean you know he's
he's King of the UK I mean how much of
that remains okay and how you does it
remain United I mean those are those are
serious issues so you've got the whole
issue of the the other Realms which she
becomes king of or is now king of 14
Realms and those you know some of those
are are very now vociferously Republican
and so uh I think it's safe to say some
of them will go Republican how do you um
sort of separate how do you how do you
de-personalize that so that it doesn't
become
um a a sort of almost a vote of no
confidence in Charles III